oh you may not think I'm pretty but
don't judge on what you see I'll eat
myself if you can find a smarter hat
than me you can keep your bowl as black
your top hat sleek and tall for I'm the
Hogwarts or tin hat and I can cap them
all if you're anything like me then the
first time you saw or read about the
sorting hat you had a host of questions
where did it come from who made it and
how does it know what houses the student
should be in hopefully today we can
answer all of the questions that you may
have the sorting hat was sewn over a
thousand years ago and at first it was
nothing more than an ordinary hat that
belonged to Godric Gryffindor the four
founders of Hogwarts Godric Gryffindor
Salazar Slytherin Rowena Ravenclaw and
Helga Hufflepuff began to wonder how
they would sort the students into houses
after they were dead eventually they
came to a decision that they would use
Godric Gryffindor hat and it was
enchanted with the combined intelligence
of all four founders as well as some of
their personal traits
now animated the hats function was to
determine which of the four houses each
student would be placed in at the start
of the school term the Sorting Hat will
be placed on a three or four legged
stool in front of the Great Hall the Hat
would sing a lengthy song as somewhat of
an introduction the song slightly varies
each year but the basic premise remains
the same explaining how it was enchanted
and the criteria for being sorted into
each individual house it is worn by
first-year students during the sorting
ceremony and after a short period of
deliberation the Hat loudly proclaims
which house they had been placed in for
all to hear
in order to speak the Hat uses a tear
along the brim as a mouth but during the
sorting ceremony this is not the case it
communicates of a quiet voice inside of
the Hat and only the person wearing the
hat can hear it is able to read and
respond to the thoughts of the person
wearing it the house the first-year
students are placed in comes down to the
different traits and characteristics
associated with each founder and in turn
each house Godric Gryffindor valued
courage and loyalty and students seem to
possess these traits will most likely be
placed in Gryffindor ravenclaw valued
knowledge and creativity
hufflepuff dedication and patience and
Slytherin ambition and cunning there is
no definitive answer as to what how
students will be placed in as a lot of
these qualities do tend to overlap of
each other and students may possess
qualities at several houses value we see
this firsthand when Harry asked the
sorting hat not to place him in
Slytherin the Hat responds by telling
Harry he could do great things in
Slytherin but eventually the Hat decides
that Harry should be placed in
Gryffindor so we can only assume that
Harry has traits valued by both
Gryffindor and Slytherin it would also
appear that the hats decision can be
swayed if the students desire to be in a
certain house is strong enough though it
may not like to admit its mistakes the
Hat has been known to be wrong on a few
occasions the decision to place Peter
Pettigrew in Gryffindor was most
certainly a puzzling choice
when we break the sorting process down
it does ultimately come down to some
guesswork as qualities you may have at a
young age may disappear or may be
replaced by different ones and it's
understandable that the Hat may be wrong
in some cases the Sultanat also
sometimes functions as a portal
providing access to the Sword of
Gryffindor and we do see the sword
pulled from the Hat by members of
Gryffindor in their times of need it has
also been known to give warning when it
detects great danger approach in the
school the advice it offers during this
time is always the same stand together
be strong from within the sorting hat is
able to see the qualities within a
person sometimes before they even
realize them themselves the Hat
represents the found in wizards and
witches of Hogwarts and is a collection
of everything positive they valued
hopefully most of your questions have
been answered and I look forward to
hearing from you in the comment section
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained